we have a deadline for the announcement
of Stargate welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
first of all sorry for this being a
quick video like this I'm doing it on my
phone so the sound's not great so please
don't get in the comments complaining
about the sound but I wanted to get this
information out to you as quickly as
possible I've literally just had an
email that confirms something I was told
a little while ago about the
announcement of Stargate and when the
deadline is for that announcement now
this person Works closely with Amazon
and MGM and they've told me that
meetings earlier on this week confirmed
that the deadline has been set now this
was a marketing meeting it was talking
about how to Market and promote this
decision once it is made the final
decision on whether we're actually even
getting Stargate has not been made even
though a lot of work is being done but
these mean scenes are supposed to lay
the groundwork for when that final
decision for when that final
signature on the contract is done so
that obviously getting the ball rolling
so when is the deadline don't forget
that you can hit the join button if you
enjoy the content you can also go and
get some brilliant merchandise from SCI
dashtrack.com and please go and
subscribe to Sidetrack sides I do lots
of quick little videos on there and I
got all the best bits from the live
shows
well it was announced a couple of weeks
ago and I spoke about on my side track
side Channel please go and check that
video out I'll put a link on the
description that
um epics this stream and service owned
by MGM which is obviously now owned by
Amazon is moving to and being rebranded
to MGM plus MGM plus Paramount plus and
then stars is becoming a Lionsgate plus
Disney plus they're not very imaginative
of these names are they but when it
becomes MGM plus and the sister channels
like MGM I think there's um there's
about four epics channels they're all
becoming NBN plus Marquee and NBN plus
driving and all these sort of things
when they do become MGM Plus on January
the 15th
that is when Stargate will be announced
by So the plan basically so far was that
the chief executive of MGM plus
announced this rebranding also announced
a bunch of new TV shows and um a couple
of other shows coming back I'm actually
really looking forward to the Billy the
Kid series I think that would be pretty
cool
but then the marketing department has
said it would be really great if we
could announced a couple of other things
just before the rebranding the idea
being to get lots of clicks on social
media that people like me will make
videos about it if they announce
Stargate and it'll get lots of attention
on the rebranding
so the deadline for the announcement of
Stargate will be January the 15th 2023
I'm really sticking my neck out with
this
because this is like you know this is
like one of those people that say it's
at the end of the world it's November
2024 and it's not like um pick a date
way in the future so that you know when
it doesn't happen you know you can't get
accused of talking [ __ ] or something so
I'm really sticking my neck out on this
it's not very far away
um but hey this is information I'm told
I'm told it in good faith and I will
tell you in good faith I'm going to
reiterate though that a final decision
on a Stargate new series again I'm being
told has not been made
they are still looking at whether they
can develop a new franchise
they are still working with Mark Fergus
and Hawk host B to develop this new
franchise and get something going they
do have a person in mind for the new
showroom which is not Brad right but
that person is currently contracted on
another project that contract runs out I
think it's towards the end of this year
they said sort of by Christmas so a bit
vague on that but that contract runs out
and as soon as that contract runs out
they can announce the new showrunner and
hopefully announce the new show
so that in a nutshell is where we are
now I did announce this I have to say on
the sides Channel please go and
subscribe to that for videos that I do
like this normally really quick and
dirty videos that just get new
information as quickly as possible
that's a really good place for that also
I do live video best bits on there so if
you don't want to sit through an hour of
our live show on a Sunday you can just
go and watch the best bits on the side
channel so that's the channel for you if
that's what you want
please get into the comments Zone tell
me what you think about this deadline we
have a date we have an idea when this
could happen and it's in the next three
months so not very far away at all
what do you think get in the comments
and tell me if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and if you enjoy the content please
consider hitting the join button and
that really supports the channel as
always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]